remote workers beware the good times of
having meetings in your pajamas from the
comfort of home might be over as more
companies demand people back to the
office elon musk is giving his workers
an ultimatum return to the workspace or
work elsewhere that's according to a
leaked email the billionaire sent to
tesla employees which tells executive
staff that they must be in the cubicle
for a minimum of 40 hours per week or
depart the company
shannon
what do you think the reaction is
to this is going to be from within tesla
well there's so many ripple effects
listen uh we have the numbers that 4.4
million people quit their jobs in april
we've got over 11 million job openings
so if you would like to go it's like
when netflix said if you can't deal with
the things that we're going to put out
maybe you shouldn't work here anymore i
mean there are other jobs out there but
listen if people have really been still
at home in their pajamas it's a pretty
sweet gig if you can get it you just
can't keep it
so i'll be interested to see what
happens but listen i had a guy at the
beginning of this on my team who was
working from puerto rico and he would
you know zoom in from the beach and i
thought well that's that's pretty sweet
if you could keep it why would you want
to give that up um but i do know that
the new york times had a um an article a
couple of weeks ago about how this is
devastating for pets and we should worry
about our animals because they're going
to be freaked out and suffer depression
when we all go back to work join the
mental health crisis exactly
um
jesse so there's been a lot of evidence
that efficiency did not drop during the
pandemic for companies we saw companies
obviously doing quite well um do you
think that it is time to go back at
least to some sort of hybrid model where
obviously we're at work right in person
here and i know it was the preference as
well to not be in remote studios but no
i did i wanted to again summer remotely
but greg dragged us all back to the
office but in hindsight that was a good
move a couple reasons to get back to the
office gossip
office gossip is currency and when you
use it appropriately it can really just
shoot you into the upper echelons of the
executive level also love connections i
know you can't find love sitting home
alone many people date in the office
many people fall in love and get married
in the office i've heard of that all
right
also if you're tall
no one knows how tall you are on zoom as
we've shown studies will prove that tall
people will excel in a corporate
environment
also the power lunch you're not having a
power lunch at home with your parents or
your
son
we got to bring the power lunch back
also
if you isolate the country anymore we're
all going to turn into mass shooters we
saw what kovac did if you stay home
alone and just stare at a screen
people are going to get violent we all
need to get back to work this is another
aspect of jesse's law i guess they could
be like jeffrey toobin you know he was
done too many zombies
you know okay
yeah but here's the thing
if covet is the reason for everybody
staying at home i mean isn't covered
like over there a few numbers are going
up but like enough of this you're in
your pajamas i mean we look like a like
a third world country i go to the
supermarket people are in their pajamas
i go to an airport people are in their
pajamas i mean it's it's crazy anymore
and honestly i really think that it's
very it it's compelling when you have an
argument or a discussion with someone in
the office i mean that you miss when
you're alone i mean my dogs can't talk i
mean we communicate but it's like we
don't have that intellectual back and
forth right yeah if there's a back to
your fourth
put on a waistband that's what the judge
is saying
i was pregnant during covet so i wanted
no waistbands whatsoever um greg you're
very pro office yes as my grandfather
used to say people who work remotely are
remotely working
did he really say that yes he uh
he tested pajamas at home
uh you gotta love
gotta love musk he's a throwback uh in
this current sea of kind of emotive
touchy-feely corporatism he's like pure
mad men you know corporations aren't
designed to be your guidance counselor
right i'm tired of this virtue signaling
i'm tired of getting emails every single
day about a new month or a new week or a
new day you know i miss the days of the
of the little you know the little what
do you call it the personnel department
the lady you take your thing you stick
it in what months are we now i don't
know where we are my point is he's
rejecting what does that time card
oh he rejects the phoniness of this
current woke corporatism that we see
everywhere disney being the latest and
he nails this by comparing the optional
choices of the white-collar worker to
the factory worker he says minimum of 40
because that's what the factory worker
does so can you you cupcake that's what
he was saying so feel free to work for
from home all right but you got to do a
minimum 40 and that is a boss move and i
love i mean bosses aren't there to be
liked they're there like the only virtue
a company has
is to employ
lots of people to make a great product
that's the only virtue you are you
should be known for the moment you step
out of that lane you end up like disney
right you ruin your reputation if you
start if you start thinking you know if
we just do more months more emails more
more
uh 5k fun runs
people are going to forget that we're a
bloodless sick company no we'll never
forget that we know what a company does
we don't need to be lied to about how
virtuous you are that's why i like him
he rejects that stuff i think he does no
fun runs no fun runs i used to do the
fun runs they are not fun ended up
throwing up a lot
save them central park i went on brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now